what's going on guys this is Rob and as
promised it is Sunday so we are starting
secret Invasion now the last time we did
this we did it all As One video which
was about 20 minutes long we're actually
gonna do this more in depth and we're
just gonna kind of break it down piece
by piece over multiple videos so in this
video we're basically going to discuss
how it was that secret Invasion happened
in the first place so this may be
familiar territory to a lot of you guys
out there who are familiar with my
channel but what this does is this
initially picks up on tarnax 4 which is
basically the home world or the throne
world of the Scrolls now one of the
things that I want to establish right
off the bat is some of you guys in your
travels may have heard of a world called
scrollos which is the Homeworld of the
Scrolls that's where they originated
from so think of it like Humanity
originated on Earth but we decided to
colonize some other world that exists
out there and then we move the capital
of our people to like that world that's
basically what happened here but the
important thing is that this takes place
in the aftermath of the cree scroll War
now that was a conflict that had
actually been going on for millions of
years and it has an origin that we're
not going to go into here in this story
but the important thing is that the cree
scroll war was effectively ended really
through a combination of different
things that all kind of happened at the
same time the arrival of Captain Marvel
from the cree the dark Phoenix Saga
different things like that but the
reality of this is that the scroll
Empire is reeling from their defeat
basically facing off against the cree
that was done at the hands of some of
the involvement of people on Earth
particularly when it came to Earth they
view it as a Backwater world and so
because of that it would basically be
like the United States having the
greatest military might in the world
being defeated by people with pitchforks
right it would just be like a huge just
slam to the ego and so what this does is
it leads to a discussion between Emperor
dorak and his military on whether or not
they should directly Target Earth but
fortunately for them Earth comes to them
and it comes in the form of the
Illuminati now this is technically this
comical covering right here is
technically the Illuminati one shot and
for those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that when the Illuminati
were initially introduced into Marvel
Comics The original One-Shot story was
actually a story that was part of the
original Civil War event and the idea is
that you basically had Reed Richards you
had Iron Man name of the Submariner uh
Black Bolt of the Inhumans doctor
strange and Professor Xavier who all
came together in wakanda and black
panther literally told them do not do
this it's not going to work it's going
to end up with Calamity uh but they
basically came together in wakanda so
they could operate off the grid and
decided that because the crease scroll
War had come so close to destroying the
world that because they all had little
pieces of information Xavier dealing
with the Phoenix Saga The Avengers and
Fantastic Four dealing with Marvel that
had they shared that information the
conflict never would have come as close
to Earth as it did and so coming
together as the Illuminati the idea is
that no one's going to know they exist
but they're always going to keep
information shared and they're going to
secretly manipulate things behind the
scenes as you can probably imagine it
ends up disastrous but the first thing
they did was show up here to the Planet
of the Scrolls and quite literally like
Reed Richards is like I came here to
tell tell you that we will not tolerate
another Invasion attempt on Earth if you
even so much as approach Earth's space
it will force us to gather and come to
you with Manpower that you could not
even imagine and the response by Xavier
is like this is a warning and of course
Tony Stark chimes in and says do not
come here or we will destroy your people
now here's an important distinction to
understand on Earth that can be done
some of the most powerful beings that
exist in the entirety of Marvel Comics
exist on Earth the molecule man who can
alter reality on a multiversal scale he
exists on Earth Franklin Richards who
can alter reality on a universal scale
he's from Earth he got all kinds of
stuff and Emperor Doric does not take
this lightly but he also won't take it
sitting down and that's one of the
things where he's just kind of like
here's the thing to understand now that
you've come here and you've made that
threat to us we weren't really sure if
we were going to invade your world
before we're going to now like this is
not something that I'm just going to
idly sit by and let happen which makes
sense right a man doesn't walk into
another man's house and start telling
him what what's what and that's exactly
what's going on here and so as a result
of that the Illuminati basically destroy
the vessel that Emperor Doric is sitting
on right they just eradicate the entire
vessel itself blow the whole thing to
pieces and fly out in their spacecraft
now of course this leads to the entire
scroll Armada just chasing after them
right because while Doric isn't killed
trying to assassinate their leader in
that way is no small thing right that's
a massive event and because it leads to
the entire scroll Armada following them
one of the things to know is that while
Earth has the most powerful beings in
existence it is not the most
technologically advanced place in the
universe the Scrolls have been around
for millions of years the cree just as
long and so what you're talking about
are people with just the ability to
achieve Interstellar travel and the
defensive and offensive capabilities to
go with it but the thing about this is
that because there's so much more
technologically advanced than the
Illuminati or really just anybody on
Earth they overtake their ship quite
readily and try as he might iron man
tries to get them out of there but It
ultimately doesn't work and and what it
does is it leads to the Scrolls
basically taking the Illuminati and then
analyzing their individual bodies they
basically go through to try to
understand Reed Richards now when it
comes to the Scrolls and read because
guys like uh like clerk who was the
original Super scroll basically a scroll
that had all the abilities of the
Fantastic Four which was really done
more through science magic than anything
else it basically led to them having
involvement with the Fantastic Four
becoming aware of read more than
anything else another particular
important thing about Reed is that he's
the smartest person in the universe so
literally every Race Across the Universe
knows how capable and intelligent Reed
Richards is so his intelligence
respected but at the end of the day the
Scrolls really function in the capacity
of just trying to figure out a way to
destroy the various powerful beings that
exist on Earth more than anything else
and so they're literally going through
and analyzing each and every one of
these guys and they talk about the
nature of them for example they don't
understand how black Bolt's vocal cords
work right how is it that he's able to
emit a quasi-sonic scream and one of the
discussions by the science guys is like
could we just rip his vocal cords out
and the answer to this is no if we did
that because we don't know how they work
we could eradicate this entire area
where the throne resides we would kill
everybody here we don't know if that
would be the case or not what's
particularly interesting to them is Tony
Stark because when they look at
everybody else and they all have powers
they look at Xavier and they're like
okay so his powers are tied to his
genome right that's not very difficult
now of course just kind of a Sidetrack
this story here and the entirety of
secret Invasion takes place before the
events of what are happening right now
in Marvel Comics which is Avengers vs
X-Men versus eternals where they're
actually changing the nature of how
mutants came into existence in the first
place so um it's not it's not an
important thing for this story but just
kind of clarifying things for people who
were sort of new to Marvel Comics in
terms of what's going on now and secret
Invasion but the thing about this is
that Tony Stark's really fascinating to
them because he's just a guy or he has
no powers he's just a dude who wears a
metal suit and like that's it and even
to the Scrolls Tony Stark's Stark Tech
his Iron Man suit is not that
technological Advanced and that's kind
of the funny thing is because of events
like secret Invasion Tony Stark actually
modifies his Iron Man suits so they
become more advanced and can actually
rival the technology of other races that
exist out there in the universe it's
just one of those instances where Tony
Stark is always learning and always
improving but the funny thing about this
is that while Tony Stark's being held
prisoner he's suddenly rescued by The
Avengers who seemingly come out of
nowhere now the funny thing here is we
would look at this and say okay cool the
day's saved but what's really wild about
this is he's like okay so here's the
thing about you guys he's like you guys
always underestimate your opponents it's
why you lost the crew scroll War so the
question that I have to ask you here is
how dumb do you really think I am and
this is when we find out it's not the
Avengers it's Scrolls posing as The
Avengers now this is a really really
cool moment because this is kind of the
the precursor to secret Invasion and
it's sort of setting the stage for like
what the Scrolls will eventually end up
doing which becomes incredibly awesome
when it happens but the reality here is
that's when the Scrolls kind of start
bickering like I told you this was about
idea we never should have tried to do
this to get information now them trying
to get information out of them will be a
very key component to what's going on
here but the thing to understand is that
because Tony Stark at least with his
combat training is able to overpower
these Scrolls it of course allows him to
basically grab some guns start shooting
the place up and start freeing each
member of the Illuminati who of course
helps to free the other members as their
freed themselves and of course this
basically leads to them basically making
their escape here but the problem here
is they're back on the chase trying to
get away from the scroll Armada if they
couldn't get away before there's no
reason to believe that they can get away
now the funny thing about this is that
what they end up doing is basically
creating a kind of Illusion using a
combination of Professor Xavier's
telepathic abilities and Doctor
Strange's magic and what they end up
doing is literally casting the solution
of Galactus appearing now there's a
reason why they chose this and I'll talk
about that here in a second here in
about one or two minutes but what this
does is it basically leads to the
Illuminati making their escape by way of
the Galactus illusion and then in turn
we switch back to the throne world and
what we end up finding out is that they
basically got exactly what they needed
what they were looking for was the
ability to duplicate superheroes they
were looking to understand exactly how
their powers worked now the problem with
this is that this project sort of Falls
slightly to the wayside it becomes just
kind of like a background science
project while the scrolls are working on
rebuilding their empire but what ends up
going on is that around this time this
leads to the introduction of varenki now
in order to understand varanki we have
to do a little bit of history when it
comes to the Scrolls right so the way
this works out is if you guys are
familiar with probably the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or Marvel Comics or
anything like that you guys are aware
that on Earth in the early days of
Humanity's existence the celestials
visited Earth and they created the
eternals the deviants and then modified
the genes of humanity so that at some
future point in time they would develop
Powers I.E the origin of mutants in
Marvel Comics Earth was not the only
place they visited and in fact the
scroll Homeworld of scrollos way back
when was one of the places they visited
the difference here is that unlike Earth
where the eternals and the deviants
engage in some kind of a war with
Humanity sort of being caught in the
middle and then the deviants were all
but just destroyed when they tried to
destroy the celestials when the
celestials arrived on Earth for a second
time unlike that when it came to the
Scrolls what you had were two people you
had clippin and Slugger and I know their
names are really really weird slugert
led the Deviant Scrolls and Cliven led
the Eternal Scrolls and then you just
had normal Scrolls they don't matter and
the reason why is because as soon as the
Deviant Scrolls came into existence they
eradicated the normal Scrolls they were
just totally destroyed and they did it
by literally just pretending to be
normal Scrolls and then just
assassinating people every chance they
got and slugert was the one who led the
entirety of the Deviant Scrolls now
Cleveland was the one who led the
Eternal Scrolls and once the Deviant
Scrolls had basically eradicated all the
normal Scrolls they killed all but one
of the eternals which was Cleveland and
what ended up happening is that
Cleveland actually orchestrated a
ceasefire and he effectively married
sluggard and then they ended into
godhood according to the stories but the
reason why that matters is because when
it came to that Essence that kind of
rising to godhood one of the things that
clippin and sluggert had done is they
had kind of written out this prophecy
that foretold that the entire nature of
the scroll race is that it's to extend
into the universe and then eventually
take over the entirety of the universe
so for the Scrolls themselves they see
the universe being ruled by them as
their divine right right like literally
their gods told him it would happen and
so this gave birth to What's called the
dardvan which is basically the religious
sect of the scroll Empire it's not
purely science and so because the
darthan had always existed as science
began to become more prominent it began
to take a back seat but varanki is a
member of the darvan she's a member of
their religious sect one of the things
that have been prophesied in addition to
the idea that the Scrolls would
basically go into space and conquer the
universe is that at some future point in
time the scroll race itself would be
eradicated by what was called quote
unquote a Devourer and they then a wave
and that's basically what varenki is
talking about here that she kind of Pops
back up again and is like look like with
my religious sex behind me Emperor Doric
you have to listen our people are going
to be destroyed we have to leave this
world right we have to leave this place
right if we don't leave the prophecy
will come true and the entirety of our
people will be destroyed the issue with
this is that it creates a bit of a civil
war where Emperor dorak basically labels
varanki as an insurrectionist and a
religious zealot his people basically
conquer and imprison her people and then
essentially just throw them away on some
desert world where they're basically
left to die and so what this does is it
switches over to the experiment that the
scrolls are conducting with trying to
find a way to successfully duplicate
superheroes and the thing about this is
that because of everything that varenki
said it kind of resonates with Emperor
dorak and so what's been going on here
is that with the experiment involving
Reed Richards who they successfully
duplicated what they do is they
literally have these situations where
Reed is just kind of cloned over and
over and over again again and each time
he's introduced to his family and his
family's so happy to see them and then
they're kind of like you know tell us
about Galactus tell us everything you
know about Galactus and the reality is
like Reed sometimes just doesn't know
anything about Galactus or he doesn't
know anything about something else but
the truth is that every time they clone
him he just simply doesn't have the
information that they need because that
information was not carried over in the
cloning process and so these members of
the Fantastic Four the family that's
here to see read it's just Scrolls
impersonating and Reed himself is
literally just a clone that's the whole
idea clone superheroes and then see if
they could replace superheroes using
clones now the kicker to all this and
the concern about Galactus comes by way
of basically Brian Michael Bendis in
this story invoking a previous story
that was written in 1983 with Fantastic
Four issue 257 and what ended up going
on here is that in effect Galactus
arrived at the throne world of the
Scrolls now this is important because
one of the pieces of technology that the
Scrolls had was the ability to cloak
their world because it's not the first
time Galactus came riding by right it's
not the first time that Galactus
appeared near them and the prophecy
being what it is if nothing else they
were always just taking precautionary
measures the reality here is that in
that story they essentially missed their
chance to cloak their world but even if
they had it wouldn't have made any
difference because Frankie Ray who is
the herald of galantis at the time knows
exactly where the scroll Throne world is
and led Galactus straight to it so there
was no way for them to hide anyway the
end result being that Galactus basically
annihilates the entirety of the throne
world now what was left of the scroll
race which was literally just kind of a
a military-led hodgepodge of the group
what ended up happening is they just
kind of limped on and then tried to
restore their their race back to
Greatness but then Annihilation happened
when the villain annihilus led the
annihilation wave Across the Universe
and almost killed everything and that
all but destroyed what was left of the
scroll race so all you really had with
regards to the Scrolls was basically
just a ragtag bunch of scientists and
the continued attempt to like find a way
to duplicate Earth superheroes but this
ultimately leads to the science Division
and even those members of the scroll
race who are still alive reaching out to
varanki and bringing her back from the
desert world where she officially
becomes Empress of the scroll Race So
for those of you guys who read secret
Invasion and you are wondering how she
became the leader during secret Invasion
this is exactly how but there's also
major changes that have taken place
major progressions to this project that
simply weren't there before and so one
of the things we find out is that one
their group is basically moved to
tarnak's 10. that's their new Homeworld
right tarnak's X but the other thing is
that varanki is informed by the science
officer of the scroll race that because
of all these advancements they no longer
have to traditionally clone superheroes
the way they did before they don't have
to clone read Richards and then try to
get information out of him instead they
can just use their shape-shifting
technology now one of the big things
here is that when it comes to the
Deviant Scrolls shape-shifting is one of
their powers the issue is that if a
scroll were to just shapeshift and then
go to Earth and then just say hey
everybody I'm Tony Stark because they're
not actually Tony Stark and because they
don't know the mannerisms of Tony Stark
people who know Iron Man would
immediately pick up on the fact that
it's not actually him kind of a sixth
sense if you want to call it that to say
nothing of telepaths who could read his
mind and immediately know that it's a
scroll and not actually Tony Stark and
so in order to get around this which
just is a genius maneuver in order to
get around this what the scrolls are
basically doing here at least what they
have been doing is traveling around and
snatching up members of the superhero
Community bringing them to the scroll
home world and then basically having
Scrolls turn into those guys and one of
the things that they say is they
basically refer to like the newest
scroll they have and we're literally
told this is the model for our new super
scroll though he resembles the physical
attributes of the warrior Clerk and his
foe Fantastic Four powers that was for
the most part scientific trickery this
is the real deal any human or mutant who
we can strip a DNA sample of we can now
utterly duplicate their abilities any
mix or match of any kind or if you want
just a hyper-powered Reed Richards or
Ben Grimm we can do that too but like
clerk displayed for many years we
believe that a warrior with a mixture of
power attributes reveals itself to be a
much more established threat the more
weapons a warrior has and ultimately the
better they become now that's where
things get really interesting because
again they hit on the idea that they
can't simply just shape-shift that in
order for this Invasion to happen in
order for them to literally invade Earth
replace superheroes and then essentially
conquer Earth which they see Earth as
their prophesized new home that a scroll
has to literally become that person that
their mind has to be altered they have
to actually believe that's the case and
so one of the things that ends up
happening and I'm not going to show you
who this person is but one of the things
that ends up happening is that there is
a person who is already on Earth who is
a scroll and has been there for quite
some time and has been operating behind
the scenes for quite some time but this
person appearing here and showing up and
basically offering testimony shows that
the project works that the Scrolls using
this process can infiltrate Earth they
can pretend to be anybody they want to
including a powerful being a person
whose abilities they can copy and they
can do this without any telepath knowing
that they're an actual scroll they can
do it without Wolverine or somebody with
enhanced senses being able to pick up on
the fact that they smell different they
can literally avoid any and all forms of
detection no one will ever know they're
an actual scroll and so in the end you
do have a ranky who basically tells them
when I was cast out right when I was
cast out and I was sent to that desert
world the Empire continued to limp wands
which means I'm not really needed here
instead I'm needed on the front lines I
myself am going to go to Earth and when
the questions asked what physical form
would you like to take she chooses it
but I'm not going to show you guys what
it is no spoilers down in the comments
action but I'm curious to see if you can
figure out what form varenki takes which
superhero does varenki basically end up
becoming in secret Invasion and I will
say this it's probably the person you
would least suspect this is where
everything picks up right this is where
the story starts getting really really
good the other thing that we have to
keep in mind though is that this part
that we're going to cover here with Nick
Fury takes place before the events of
Civil War and we'll explain why that
matters here in a second but Nick Fury
is basically underground now all this is
really the aftermath of a story called
fury secret War which is basically where
Nick Fury launched an unsanctioned
attack against Liberia which was not
ruled by Dr Doom at the time but because
it was unsanctioned and things basically
went South It ultimately led to him
being kicked out as director of shield
and then a warrant being put out for his
arrest after which point he just kind of
disappeared he just went underground
which is where he's at right now but the
other thing about this is that this also
deals with the arrival of Valentina
right like Contessa Valentina you guys
know her from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because she's being played by
Julia Louise Dreyfus in the comics her
and Nick Fury have had a kind of
on-again off-again romantic relationship
and if anything it was really one out of
necessity right they were both basically
just pumping each other for information
but both were kind of on board with it
because I guess they just wanted a bang
but one of the things that Contessa
reveals is that in the aftermath of fury
secret war that Maria Hill has been
promoted to director of shield and
everybody who knows Nick Fury has
basically been suspended indefinitely
from Shield The Only Exception being
dumb dumb Dugan just because of the fact
that he was Fury's right hand man and
it's better to have Dum dumdogan on
board because Dugan's alliances are to
Fury but they're also doing the right
things so he could kind of go either way
but the thing about this is that of
course the two of them end up spending
the night together and then when they
wake up the next morning Contessa tells
Fury she's gonna go get breakfast now
one of the things to know about Nick
Fury because the Marvel Comics what you
have right now is you've got like the
black guy Nick Fury right Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury or Nick Fury Jr as they call
him this is back in the day when you had
like the old white guy Nick Fury and so
what this means is that this version of
Nick Fury was always suspicious of
everybody and he would literally just
stay suspicious until you gave him a
reason not to now a lot of that's just
because of his time fighting in World
War II with the Howling Commandos
becoming a CIA agent then become
director of Shield that kind of a thing
so his life is literally just mired in
war and in suspicion and the result of
this is that when Contessa leaves he
activates a device on his wrist that
allows him to bend light around him
making him invisible and then follows
her and what he realizes is she's
actually meeting with somebody who
appears to be part of just some group
out there that maybe has it out for Nick
Fury or whatever the case is but the
kind of things they're saying confirm
the suspicions of Fury when they're
saying things like will I have his trust
give me time and I'll get the
information we need so on and so forth
but obviously this is either not
Contessa or Contessa is working and
turning against Fury and is likely going
to try to turn him over into some
capacity and so when she arrives Nick
Fury is already ready he's literally got
a gun in his hand he's sitting in a
chair and he's like who are you really
and of course one of the things to know
about Fury is he'll ask that question a
couple times if Nick Fury asked you that
question who are you really assume it's
rhetorical assume he already knows the
answer that you're not who you claim to
be and where she tries to sort of Dodge
and Bob and weave and like what are you
doing Put the gun down like that kind of
a thing he literally is just like one
more time who are you really and he's
showing no signs that like he kind of
believes her or she's getting him to let
his guard down you know it's one of
those things where he's like who were
you really and when she doesn't answer
the question he immediately shoots her
and she turns into a scroll and that's
what when Marvel basically confirms Nick
Fury is the first one to figure out that
scrolls are invading Earth he's the
first one to find out what happens now
in terms of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's probably gonna end up
happening with Samuel Jackson he's gonna
be the first one to realize what's going
on so they're basically taking the
element of this story and carrying it
over to the MCU regarding his character
but following that he basically goes to
a rooftop he spies on the guys that the
scroll was meeting with and he realizes
they're speaking in a scroll dialect so
he's like okay she's not the only one
it's not a one-off right like there are
multiple Scrolls on earth now the
question is what do they want and so
what he ends up doing is he actually
breaks into the shield Helicarrier like
its main base of operations and when he
gets in he starts talking to like Maria
hill now that's the other thing about
Nick Fury Nick Fury was ridiculously
capable and it's kind of funny because
he basically knows Shield inside and out
because a lot of the systems that Shield
uses he developed or had them developed
for shield so he literally knows all the
back doors he knows how to sneak in and
even when Shield went back and modified
the systems because obviously why would
you move into a house and never change
the locks when the previous owner leaves
that even all of that Nick Fury is so
capable he can still get in undetected
that's just how good he is as an agent
right he's just that capable and so
Maria Hill is initially taken off guard
but Nick Fury does not come here to
provoke a fight he comes here to
basically tell her there's some things
you need to do right because remember
this takes place before Civil Wars so
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with what that means during the events
of Civil War because Maria Hill had
effectively just bungled the entire
superhero conflict and because she
operated with two extreme of a hand in a
lot of ways it was her feeling
underestimated by the people around her
so she was just over compensating and
torpedoed her career in the process that
Tony Stark ends up becoming the new
director which is actually what you'll
find when we transition into the next
part of the story in this video but the
thing about this is that at this point
in time she's the head of Shield right
she's the one running the show and so
that's why Fury's like now that you have
this gig now that you have this job Fury
one already knows she's not a scroll
right he's looked into her and we'll
find out how he does that here in a
second but he basically already looked
into her he knows that it's actually
Maria Hill he literally tells her you're
surrounded on all sides by people who
have it out for you I.E Nick Fury saying
there are a ton of Scrolls on this ship
he's not telling her their Scrolls but
he's like there's a ton of people here
who are who have it out for you and it's
only a matter of time before they make
that move against you number two
whenever you have that itch on the back
of your neck that feeling of uncertainty
that's your gut talking to you learn to
trust it learn to believe that and what
you need to do is start developing life
model decoys make like a dozen of those
things right and just start sending them
out whenever you're unsure about what's
going on whenever you get that little
feeling on the back you your neck and
your your gut is telling you something's
off send a life model decoy in your step
and the last thing he says is like I'm
gonna be watching you I'm gonna be
keeping an eye on you and if any point
along the line I think you're not who
you really are I'll kill you on spot
right like basically if she's replaced
by a scroll I will take you out and so
Maria Hill has no idea what Nick Fury is
talking about but one of the things to
notice here is that while her loyalties
are to shield and while she does it does
basically activate a code white which is
the highest level code they have
available like basically this is like an
immediate coming together of Shield
agents everybody mobilize take out that
Target right just like oh my God like
it's a great big huge thing did she also
understand the importance of Nick Fury
she also understands the significance of
Nick Fury and he would not break into
the shield Helicarrier headquarters risk
getting caught even though it was never
going to happen just to convey those
messages to Maria Hill so she can ignore
it right like it's one of those things
where she literally takes it to heart
and so what you end up doing is of
course Nick Fury just kind of disappears
right he literally just activates a
beacon that basically makes them
invisible to not only the human eye but
as well as radar so they just don't know
where he went to he just vanishes like
like a fart in the wind and so he ends
up meeting with Spider-Woman Jessica
Drew now one of the things to know here
about Spider Woman is that she was
initially brought in by Nick Fury and
she's effectively a spy initially she
was a spy that basically worked on
behalf of Nick Fury infiltrating Hydra
and then she was a spy for shield which
is what she is right now but she ends up
becoming kind of a triple agent
basically working for Nick Fury in the
sense that she was spying on Hydra
that's no longer a thing anymore we'll
talk about that here in a minute she is
currently a shield agent but of course
they're highly suspicious of her because
of her history with Nick Fury now Nick
Fury basically approaches her and is
like I need you to spy on shield and I
need you to spy on the superheroes right
unlike the Avengers in those groups and
report back to me anything you find now
one of the things that Nick Fury also
reveals and the way that he kind of
monitors Spider-Woman and knows that
Spider Woman is not a scroll is that
he's basically been keeping an eye on
her for two weeks he's literally just
been watching her this whole time
watching her movements watching her
comings and goings everything and it's
kind of a fun anything because Nick Fury
is just that suspicious of everybody he
meets but when she starts asking him
questions like why do you want me to spy
on superheroes and shield and you're
basically turning me into a triple agent
the response to Fury is because it's a
much bigger thing and that's all that I
can tell you but again it's one of those
situations where when Nick Fury shows up
on your doorstep and says I need you to
do something for me you usually assume
it's for the greater good because Nick
Fury never really does anything for
extremely selfish motivations he never
really does anything to just cover
himself up right and so ultimately
because of the respect she has for Nick
Fury that Spider Woman gets on board and
so what this does is it transitions over
to a regathering of the Illuminati now
this is when we talk about kind of the
bigger picture anybody who's read
anything online about secret Invasion
most all of you have heard somewhere
along the line the idea that the
superheroes learned about secret
Invasion because it turned out Elektra
was a scroll so that happened in a new
Avengers story was a five part story and
we can cover it if you want to but it
has nothing to do with anything until
you get to like the last two or three
pages when Elektra dies when the new
Avengers launch an assault on the hand
which is like a mystical ninja
organization and when Elektra dies she
turns into a scroll that's all you
really have to know right following that
basically what had happened is Spider
Woman had taken the body of Elektra to
Iron Man and was like what in the hell
is going on like what is this like why
do we have a scroll on The Avengers team
what's happening here and so with Iron
Man having no idea what was going on
with that he basically brings the body
of Elektra to a new Gathering of the
Illuminati and when they all come
together they don't even know what's
going on right like like Iron Man's the
only one that knows what's happening and
in fact even when Namor shows up Neymar
believes it's the body of Captain
America because this segment takes place
after the events of Civil War and even
after the death of Captain America which
was not technically part of Civil War
But ultimately the Iron Man's like no
this is a scroll and so it's kind of
like okay like how did a scroll
Infiltrate The New Avengers and that's
the question of Tony Stark is I don't
know like we don't know like we didn't
even know she was a scroll nobody knew
she was a scroll right like what's going
on here when it comes to the new
Avengers there's two people on that team
who would have immediately picked up on
the fact that she was a scroll the first
was Peter Parker's Spider Sense and even
if Peter didn't know exactly what was
going on because every time Spider-Man
looked at a lecture his spider since
would have gone off even though it just
would have seemed weird maybe Elektra
had it out for him he would just kind of
be suspicious with Wolverine and all of
his enhanced senses he would have
immediately been able to pick up on the
fact that's not Elektra but for whatever
reason and by whatever means the Scrolls
can evade that the Scrolls can literally
Dodge Spider-Man so it never goes off
and Wolverine's senses never detect that
they're not who they claim to be and so
it's one of those things where it's like
okay how did this start and that's what
Iron Man's like were the ones who did it
like how do you think it started we
caused this and so of course this
references the last video we did which
of course again you're welcome to check
out the playlist in the description so
you can keep track of it all so you
won't get lost with all the videos we
make here on the channel but in that
video we talked about how when the
Illuminati first formed the first thing
they did was show up to the scroll home
world and basically tell them if you
bring your war with a Cree close to
Earth like that again we will annihilate
all of you and the response of the
Scrolls basically took them captive and
then started basically working on their
genes or trying to find a way to
understand their genes and then at a
future point in time when the scroll
world was destroyed by Galactus that the
Scrolls began the process of replacing
superheroes on Earth and so were the
members of the Illuminati are kind of
full of hubris and are just sort of like
no man like all we did was go there and
warn them and that kind of a thing Iron
Man's like no we caused this like we're
the reason why this happens we can't
tell anybody that right we can't tell
anybody that we're the reason this this
whole thing happened but at the end of
the day we're the reason behind it all
now the other thing that's kind of
interesting here is a lot of members of
the Illuminati are kind of like okay
well what if it's just one like what if
what if it's just a scroll like a rogue
scroll that defected from the empire for
whatever reason and basically just took
over you know just replaced Electra
right like which by the way where is the
real Electra and it's kind of like I
don't know she's missing or she's dead
like I have no clue where she is all I
know is like she's just the Elektra here
right that's Iron Man's response like
just the scroll that we see in front of
us but the other thing that Iron Man
says is like this is the one we found
but we have to assume there's more we
can't just look at this Electra scroll
and see it here and say well we'll we'll
worry about it if it happens some more
we have to assume that there are more
Scrolls that are that have infested
Earth in some capacity and so as a
result of that basically the entire
reality of the situation hits home when
you have this discussion or really this
moment where black bull which is
probably one of the the only three
moments of Marvel Comics when he's ever
been cool uh what he basically like
speaks right and literally says actually
I have a better idea I take the body and
your people die so that my people can
live now here's the reason why that
matters and it catches the entirety of
the Illuminati off guard because Black
Bolt has a quasi-sonic screen that's the
reason he doesn't talk because if you
were to talk he'd probably kill
everybody in the room but the fact that
Black Bolt can speak without basically
putting off or really just releasing his
voice tells him right off the bat that's
not Black full but even that realization
is irrelevant because as soon as it
happens he basically lets solve an
enormous amount of energy that doesn't
really kill everybody here but certainly
incapacitates them for a moment and
takes them off guard now of course
they're basically shielded just because
of their insanely fast reactions but
this scroll and it's one of the cool
things about it because this scroll had
replaced Black Bolt remember when the
secret Invasion project was undertaken
by the scroll Empire they have the
ability to mix and match Powers however
they see fit so they could literally
create a scroll or give the abilities to
a scroll that has the powers of
Spider-Man and Wolverine all rolled into
one if they chose to in this instance
because this scroll is infiltrating the
Illuminati it has all the powers of the
Illuminati it's got the telepathy of
Charles Xavier the strength of name of
the Submariner the elasticity of uh of
Reed Richards like it has all those
things right even the Quasi Sonic scream
of Blackpool of course in this instance
it can control the scream instead of it
controlling him but where you end up
having Professor Xavier that tries to
use his telepathy on this guy in order
to bring it down it doesn't work right
like Xavier's telepathy does not work in
at all and in fact this guy is able to
provide a telepathic feedback loop
that's basically two brick walls
smashing into each other but the scroll
is able to overcome it and Xavier is
temporarily incapacitated which by the
way for those of you guys who are
curious how it is that Professor Xavier
is walking basically when he came back
after the events of House of M he had
regained his ability to walk there's the
answer to your question so the thing
behind this and what's really crazy here
is Doctor Doom encases this guy in the
Crimson bands of sidorak which he's able
to break out of right this guy's
strength is on a whole different level
and so ultimately name of the Submariner
breaks this guy's neck and then throws
him onto a piece of rebar and basically
just kills him on the spot right now of
course this pisses off Iron Man and then
because it's like okay like this guy had
information but what we end up finding
out is this is not the only one like him
in fact there's multiple Scrolls who are
basically agents there to take out the
Illuminati all of whom are just as
capable as that guy is and so with the
group struggling against one having to
face off against two or three is even
more complicated than that and there's
no real discernible way for the group to
make it out alive so Iron Man does the
only thing he can can do because of the
fact that this fight with that first
scroll had depleted his energy down to
like 20 something percent and his suit
was not able to maintain he tells the
Illuminati to get out of there as fast
as they possibly can he Taps into a
nearby nuclear reactor like he literally
supercharges his armor and then just
lets off all this atomic energy in a
massive blast now the funny thing about
this is no one knew that Iron Man can do
that this is one of those instances when
the Iron Man is basically given a new
power that we never saw before so it is
cool to be able to see him tap into a
nuclear reactor absorb all that nuclear
energy and then let it off in the form
of what's effectively a small scale like
a small yield nuclear warhead it's
pretty awesome to see because he's
basically now a walking talking nuclear
bomb so that's kind of nuts but Iron Man
also says like the Scrolls didn't know
that I could do that either but now they
do and now that they do know it won't
work twice it's not going to work again
this is kind of Marvel's way of saying
like you're never going to see this
power again in Marvel Comics at least
not in the form of this story but the
important thing here and what's really
crazy is Xavier picked up on something
that when Xavier tried to read the mind
of that scroll he came to this
realization that yes the scroll
Replacements are duplicates if you want
him call him that were able to dodge the
abilities of like Spider-Man and
Wolverine and being able to detect that
they were actual Scrolls but they can
also Dodge the telepathic abilities of
telepaths indirectly and the reason why
is because telepaths basically rely on
of course the mental patterns the
thoughts you have going on in your head
to understand what's happening here but
what Xavier says is that scroll believed
he was Black Bolt like that scroll
legitimately thought he was blackballed
and in turn turned against all of us now
of course in that moment when that
scroll turned against them its true
thoughts became manifested its true
thoughts were real but what Xavier
saying here is that when they all came
together in the first place and Xavier
was reading the thoughts of Black Bolt
before he turned before he revealed
himself as a scroll in order to know
what Black Bolt was thinking in their
meeting as far as Xavier was aware that
was Black Bolt so until such a time as a
scroll reveals their true motivations
and actually activate themselves and
reveal themselves as a scroll and stop
not being the person they're pretending
to be there's no conceivable way for a
telepath to know that it's actually a
scroll that's why this is a secret
Invasion that's why the secret Invasion
event even happened in the first place
because there's no way for the
superheroes on Earth to basically detect
that a person is an actual scroll what
this does is it basically starts to
destroy the trust between the members of
the Illuminati which had already walked
a knife set right they already came
together but they did it because they
felt like they had to not because they
truly wanted to and because that trust
was already so flimsy in the first place
now that they're all facing this
situation where the reality is any of
them could be a scroll there's no way to
know for sure name where the Submariner
is the first one to be like I don't
trust any of you here and he leaves and
that sows the seeds of Doubt among the
rest of the team because while they
don't openly come out and say it it's
literally the standoff at the end of The
Good the Bad and the Ugly they're all
just kind of looking at each other and
it's like are you a school I don't know
are you a scroll like it's a more
serious version of like the Spider-Man
meme that's basically what this is and
so ultimately even if only for a
temporary moment the entirety of the
Illuminati seemingly disband so what we
do here is we initially pick up with
Tony Stark meeting with Reed Richards
and Hank Pym now here's the thing the
way that Tony Stark talks to Reed
Richards and simply saying that like you
and Hank Pym are the smartest like two
of the smartest men in the world and
that's why I'm bringing this to you Reid
Richards is surprised by the fact that
like Elektra is a scroll now those are
the guys who have followed are covered
so far Reed Richards already knows this
because he's a member of the Fantastic
Four and he's a member of the Illuminati
so pray tell why Reed Richards is
surprised in this story to learn that
Elektra is a scroll because Brian
Michael bindis is writing it and if you
don't know anything about Marvel Comics
this is something that you need to be
aware of Ryan Michael bindis is
notorious for two things putting way
more text in a comic than he needs to
and ignoring stuff sometimes Ryan
Michael Bendis will ignore the things he
wrote which this is a perfect example of
it the alternative is the excuse that we
as fans made up which is that Reed
Richards is pretending because nobody's
supposed to know he's a member of the
Illuminati so in front of Hank Pym he's
acting like oh man this is crazy I can't
believe something like this happened
good thing I didn't know about it
beforehand because now I could do
whatever it is I need to do in order to
find some way to stop this it's the only
way that we know how to rationalize it
as fans that's why a lot of us were just
really excited when Bendis left and went
to DC and then he screwed up Superman
but the thing about this is that once
that Revelation is brought forward this
switches over to the peak because start
bringing this to the the attention of
Reed and Hank Pym is that they can put
their minds to task and they can figure
out how it is that Elektra was able to
be replaced by a scroll and that scroll
was able to avoid the detection of
virtually everybody but for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the peak
this is the main base of operations for
the sentient World observation and
response department now this group is
similar to Shield but not directly so
sword was created out of Shield that if
Shield monitors the various threats that
exist on Earth then Shield came to the
realization and really even Nick Fury
himself came into the realization there
needs to be an organization that it
monitors threats in space hence the
reason why sword was born and that's
literally what they do they just monitor
as much of space as they possibly can
because they can't see it all and they
basically keep an eye on whatever
threats may be approaching earth right
so like if Galactus is coming to Earth
sword will know about it and then
they'll just have to evacuate because
there's basically nothing they can do
but that's the thing to kind of keep in
mind here but sword is a very strategic
operation and being able to understand
what threats exist out there that could
potentially be targeting Earth the
kicker about all this is they pick up on
basically an object or a ship making its
way towards Earth and what's really
crazy about this is Iron Man immediately
takes off and then contacts the mighty
Avengers to have them respond as well as
Luke Cage there's a couple things to
understand here when it comes to this
segment first and foremost the reason
why Luke Cage is against this and the
reason why his team is referred to as
The Secret Avengers is because in the
aftermath of Civil War when basically
Iron Man won and he became the new
director of shield and the 50 state
initiative was invoked and superhuman
registration became the law of the land
you had two things that happened the
first is that most all of the Avengers
basically went underground they
abandoned the entire role because they
didn't want to have anything to do with
registration and they steadily stood
fast against it but the other part of
this is that with most of the Avengers
basically leaving Tony Stark Tony Stark
took those Avengers that were on his
side and seeing it as kind of a fresh
start so to speak basically created the
mighty Avengers and so the mighty
Avengers that's the heavy hitting team
right that's like Carol Danvers that's
the God of War Aries it's the century
Robert Reynolds more than enough to
handle virtually any threat that could
show up on Earth outside of just some
crazy level Cosmic entity like Galactus
but they're pretty Heavy Hitters the
kicker about all this is that in order
for The Secret Avengers to basically get
to where it is that this ship is Crash
Landing at they basically travel to
Avengers Tower they still the
Helicarrier steal the The Vessel of Tony
Stark and then race off now of course
Tony Stark could basically shut it down
remotely so of course they basically
deactivated right they deactivate the
motherboard so they can basically just
travel to wherever it is they need to
travel to and that's it but not having
to worry about Tony Stark shutting it
down but the reality here is they
ultimately end up arriving in the Savage
land and they get there at least shortly
after they arrive there Iron Man arrives
as well now the fact that these guys are
all Secret Avengers they defy the whole
role of like superhero registration all
that kind of stuff that's the reason why
Tony Stark wants to arrest them right
because of the fact that they're
literally vigilantes in the eyes of the
law and so you do have a bit of a
skirmish that kind of breaks out between
them where literally it's superhero
facing off against superhero to a degree
is more of a standoff than anything else
but while that's going on it's all being
monitored by Abigail brand and sword and
that's when dum dum Dugan who has
historically been one of Shield's top
agents and is really kind of a field
advisor here on sword when it's revealed
that he's a scroll and when Luke Cage
pries open this ship basically rips open
the door it sets off an alarm and that
basically tells dum dum Dugan to make
his move at which point he blows up the
peak he literally destroys the sword
base now this is huge because what this
does is it basically removes Earth's
ability to recognize any potential
threats coming from space they won't
know anything right I mean there's
satellite systems and things like that
but the other part of this and it's
really like a multi-faceted strike and
it's a genius maneuver by the Scrolls
what they also do is Jarvis who has
always been like the butler of the
Avengers in the MCU he's an AI created
by Tony Stark in Marvel Comics he's a
literal guy like he's a physical guy an
actual Butler that basically exists out
there but what happens is he literally
uploads a virus to basically the
Avengers database which allows it to not
just affect like Tony Stark but the rest
of the world as well but what it does is
it shuts down the armor of Tony Stark
right so now Tony Stark's entire armor
system is nullified and it's not just
that armor it's every suit of armor he
has there's no redundancies anymore
there's no backups no nothing right like
it's just Tony Stark without any
technology at his disposal it's
basically the Scrolls launching a
multi-pronged strike again the Earth
shutting down virtually every
technological system they have and in
fact this whole attack is so intense
that Maria Hill who basically is the
kind of interim director of Shield at
the moment with Tony Stark basically off
out in the field that she's literally
like this is a Mayday this is an SOS we
have just complete and total
communication failure and she literally
tells everybody on the Helicarrier
abandoned and the reason why is
because the Helicarrier has been shut
down and it's just crashing into the
city of New York right literally getting
ready to crash land the other part of
this strike is it takes down the
satellite systems of the United States
and really the world as a whole so
there's no detection systems whatsoever
the entire technological stance of the
Earth has been reverted back a few
hundred years but to make everything
just to really put the cherry on top the
next part of this strike targets the
raft now for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with the raft this was
actually the first story that was done
by Brian Michael Bendis when he wrote
New Avengers but basically the raft is a
super villain prison and the most
extreme of these villains the molecule
man Owen Reese who can alter reality on
a on a universal scale people like that
right Victor Von Doom who's apparently
being held prisoner that they're all
held in the sub base what this virus
making its attack every single person
who's part of this base ends up getting
freed and so what it does is it switches
over to the Thunderbolts mountain now
filthy guys who are unfamiliar with
Thunderbolts mountain and this is a
pretty significant thing Thunderbolts
mountain is basically the the location
of Norman Osborne's Thunderbolts team
that you did have the Thunderbolts who
and who existed initially Thunderbolts
returned doing Shield under the control
of Baron Zemo in Marvel Comics post
Civil War Thunderbolts had basically
been modified to where it was more of
like a Suicide Squad type team that
basically it's where super villains
would be held and they would be they
would operate as like agents trying to
quote unquote atone for their actions so
it still maintained that original
charter the difference here is that
under Norman Osborne this is going to be
come ridiculously important in fact
Norman Osborne is going to prove to be
one of the most significant people if
not the most significant person that has
a hand in the events of secret Invasion
I'm not gonna go super in depth into
that but you'll figure it out by the
time we get to the end but the other
part of this is we basically switch over
to the Fantastic Four and this shows you
just how extensive the Scrolls ability
to infiltrate Society is the Fantastic
Four has some of the most advanced
Security in the world so much so that
even with these attacks these strikes
Happening by the Scrolls and taking down
like multiple facets of Technology
across the world the Fantastic Four are
actually immune to it because of the
technological advancements of Reed
Richards that it basically allows them
to operate on kind of a redundant power
system outside of any sort of network
connection but Scrolls being as they are
in this story and being able to operate
undetected by any superheroes on Earth
it allows one of them to impersonate
Susan's storm to enter into the
Fantastic Four and in doing so basically
activate the portal to the negative zone
now the reason why this is so huge those
of you guys who aren't familiar with
that the reason why this is big is
because the negative zone is composed of
antimatter right the positive the the
Marvel Multiverse as we know it is
composed a positive matter this is like
an Unstoppable Force meeting an
immovable object say for example this
portal were to just grow to the size of
a universe or something like that it
would negate the existence of the
Multiverse as a whole it would destroy
everything now of course the Scrolls
aren't looking to annihilate all
existence across the Multiverse they're
simply looking to make Earth
uninhabitable but this is them setting
the stage because what it does is it
creates a distraction for the Fantastic
Four because it literally starts sucking
everything in around it and so to really
set things off here and what's really
really Bonkers is that once the heroes
back in the Savage land right where the
vessel had basically crashed that what
this does is it basically shows that
like all these different variations of
the Avengers start emerging from this
ship you have like the X-Men you've got
like the the main Avengers roster itself
and you even have just Heroes that kind
of exist out there right people like
Luke Cage and so on and so forth the
funny thing about this is that they're
all for the most part wearing older
costumes and so it's literally the older
superheroes meeting the newer
superheroes the reason why that's such a
huge deal is because of the fact that
these guys emerge and start talking like
they've been kidnapped this whole time
right they they're like oh my God it's
so good to finally make it back home and
so what it does is it starts to kind of
beg this question who's actually a
scroll here is it like the superheroes
who have just been on Earth this whole
time is it the superheroes who are
arriving on Earth from like this scroll
ship and I know that on the surface
right now it's like well it's obvious
the ones who arrived on Earth from the
ship are Scrolls but things are going to
get a lot more complicated and a lot
Messier but when you switch back over to
the Stark lab where you have Reed
Richards and you have uh Hank Pym that
basically Reed Richards figures out how
it is the scrolls are able to basically
operate without being detected by
telepathy or any of that stuff I and as
soon as he turns to Hank Pym and tells
him that it's revealed that Hank Pym is
a scroll who basically incapacitates
Reed Richards and then just kind of
leaves it there right so what this does
here and this is this is a pretty
significant thing what this does here is
it switches over to the main
Thunderbolts themselves now under any
normal circumstance I probably wouldn't
cover this just because of the fact that
it's like okay I mean it's cool you know
but like I said Norman Osborne is going
to be a huge player by the time you get
to the end of this story and in fact
it's going to set the stage for a whole
bunch of stuff that comes after but what
basically goes on here is basically
Marvel attacks thunderbolt's mountain
now here's the thing to understand
Marvel's dead right this guy's dead so
obviously this Marvel is either one to
somehow return to life or he's a scroll
the reality is that he's a scroll right
I mean we're not really going to follow
his story anymore over the course of
this video series so we can just kind of
throw it there but the reality here is
that it takes the entirety of
thunderbolts Mountain by surprise one
because of the fact that this attack was
lost in two because Marvel died of
cancer it was actually a huge Landmark
story that Marvel wrote back in 1984 by
Jim Starlin I think but it was basically
called the death of Captain Marvel the
guy died of cancer and it was one of the
first times in Marvel Comics when they
introduced a means by which a superhero
could die and there's no conceivable way
of saving their life there was no way to
stop the cancer in Marvel's body I mean
I guess you could have right like here's
The Infinity Gauntlet let's just fix him
right but I'm pretty sure in the story
they nullified all possible options and
he'd even made peace with it and was
just kind of like okay it's cool right
it's my time to go that sort of thing
and basically just moved on but Marvel
was immensely powerful right he had the
ability to manipulate Cosmic radiation
which made him just hugely capable now a
lot of this was because of the mega
bands different things like that that he
used but the fact is he overtakes the
entirety of the Thunderbolts team and so
once the whole team is basically
defeated it leads to Norman Osborne
basically stepping up and saying hey man
so like you literally just trashed the
entirety of my of my whole Mountain do
you want to sit down and have a
conversation with it so I know that this
is one of those things where it doesn't
seem seem overly important it seems
wildly unnecessary it'll become very
important later on down the line but
jumping back into the main secret
Invasion story that what it does is
picking up in the Savage land again on
one side you have like we can we can
call them like the modern superheroes
and we can call the other ones like the
older superheroes right just to kind of
differentiate between the two and make
it easier to keep track of everything
the modern superheroes are absolutely
certain of the fact that they are human
beings who have lived on Earth this
entire time the older superheroes
believe the exact same thing that they
are those superheroes as you can imagine
it creates a huge sense of confusion now
one of the things that happens here is
there's a few tips that you get right
from the modern Avengers who are like
this is obviously not the Avengers team
these guys are Scrolls one because like
Captain America is there right by this
point in time in Marvel Comics Captain
America had already been shot and killed
by agent 13 right like he was already
dead and out of the picture and so it's
one of those things where like the fact
that he's here doesn't really make any
sense unless that Captain America
America who died was actually a scroll
but his body never reverted so he stayed
human the whole time whenever a scroll
dies they revert back to their scroll
form so that indicates this Captain
America is not actually a scroll and
that kind of gives the rest of the team
license to believe that all the old
superheroes are Scrolls and that they as
the modern superheroes are actual humans
but this is when stuff starts to get
murky because some of the Scrolls
overplay their hand for example one of
the Scrolls starts talking to Robert
Reynolds now the reality here is this is
just Brian Michael Bendis getting Sentry
out of the way because if we're being
honest with ourselves that guy's
powerful enough to end the conflict like
that right he could just end it just in
an instant but remember the alter ego of
Robert Reynolds is the void right it's
just evil Persona and the part of
himself that he's always trying to keep
at Bay and so when the vision when when
older Vision attacks Robert Reynolds he
actually tells him Robert Reynolds you
did all this right lest we forget your
alternate ego right the void has the
ability to alter reality and I am the
void and I did all this because you
wanted it to you won did it happen
subconsciously and it basically sees
Robert Reynolds take away it's stupid
don't get me wrong it's ridiculously
stupid right it would be really really
cool to see Sentry here here's one of
the things to know about Ronald Robert
Reynolds and Marvel Comics it's usually
whenever he shows up it's pointless
because a writer will bring him in and
then immediately write him out because
the writer will realize oh my God this
guy's way too powerful to be here we got
to somehow get him out of the story and
call it a day and that's exactly what
happens here because the century is
basically Marvel's Superman outside of
like Hyperion right like the century and
Hyperion are just two of the physically
strongest characters that exist in
Marvel Comics and in fact the Century's
Gone toe-to-so With The Incredible Hulk
multiple times and in fact the
Incredible Hulk is scared of the Void
because of how powerful he is so it's
just one of those things to know the
kind of a funny circumstance here is
again at this point in time in Marvel
Comics Hawkeye is operating as Ronin you
guys may remember him from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but the thing about
this is that he observes more than
anything else did he basically subdues
his older counterpart and then takes off
in the woods to watch and that's one of
the things to know about Hawkeye when it
comes to how he was written following
his return in the aftermath of House of
M that basically he just kind of
observes and watches things that he
doesn't really engage a whole lot in any
of these events but it's just one of
those things where he just kind of sees
what's going on now Carol Danvers ends
up getting Tony Stark to safety but
that's when you start to see the reality
of the situation starting to really hone
in and box people in that Tony Stark
tells Carol Danvers okay look all of my
suits are gone so I'm going to use the
one thing the Scrolls can't duplicate
which is my brain I'm literally gonna
have to rebuild an Iron Man suit from
scratch because in the Savage land you
do have forms of technology it was used
by Magneto as a base of operations at
one point it's been used by other people
they've brought technology there they've
done experiments different things like
that and so while this technology here
in the Savage land is nowhere near as
modern or fancy as Tony Stark's normal
Tech it is enough for him to get the job
done but Carol Danvers and hearing this
starts to kind of question whether or
not Tony Stark is a scroll and that's
when you switch over to like Wolverine
encountering Luke Cage Wolverines the
exact same way that Luke Cage is like
hey man it's cool it's me like I'm I'm
just regular Luke Cage and Wolverine's
like I don't care but I don't care if
you're a Luke Cage I don't care if you
say you're Luke Cage I can't trust you
and in fact Wolverine's going to attack
him now the response of Luke Cage is
dude I have indestructible skin your
claws cannot hurt my skin and the
response of Wolverine is well then I got
an indestructible claws so I guess at
the moment we're just kind of an impasse
and like we'll just sort of call it a
day but the the version of Spider-Man
the older Spider-Man is basically just
kind of laying there in the aftermath of
everything that had happened he was
killed by Hawkeye and is basically
released reverts back into a scroll and
so because that is one of those things
where Hawkeye just kind of keeps an eye
on the situation but you have older
Hawkeye who's a scroll who's basically
been killed by Mockingbird and as he
lays dying Wolverine comes to this
realization that what's actually going
on here with these Scrolls is they
genuinely believe they're these Heroes
right that's the reason why they were
able to operate undetected is because
these guys who were Scrolls either don't
know they were Scrolls or they had their
mind modified in such a way to where
they genuinely believe they are these
Heroes and that's why Wolverine draws
this conclusion and saying all the older
superheroes are Scrolls if they emerge
from that ship they are Scrolls and
that's when he goes racing over to
Mockingbird Bobby Morris with the
intention of killing her now at that
point modern Hawkeye steps in and says
no no no you're not gonna kill her and
it's like it's one of those things where
he's like we have to put her to a test
right we have to test whether or not
she's actually Mockingbird so I'm going
to ask her a question if she can answer
this question then that means that she's
actually who she claims to be and what
he does is he says tell me about October
12th and that's what we end up learning
that Bobby Morse that mockingbird was
pregnant at one point in time and she
ended up having a miscarriage and never
told anybody but October 12th is when
their kid was going to be born having
knocked out like the actual day of that
child's birth and it would have been a
beautiful day and literally Hawkeye
takes out his evidence enough to just
kind of be like okay because in his mind
he's like you died right like this baby
that we were gonna have like you died so
so like one it was a miscarriage then
you were dead so like it seemed like
there was no conceivable way to put this
together but using those two things
Hawkeyes just like it's definitely
Mockingbird right it's definitely her
but that's where the seeds of Doubt are
being planted because the question here
is is this actually Mockingbird right is
it actually her and like she was taken
by the Scrolls or whatever it is she was
held prisoner for any number of reasons
and she's actually arrived here on Earth
and she is an actual human so this
vessel contained a combination of humans
and Scrolls or is she an actual scroll
and it's just the memories of
Mockingbird were put into her head and
she genuinely believes she's that person
that's where the seeds of Doubt come
into play that's where the question
really gets answered who's a human and
who's a scroll who do you trust and so
is kind of a last ditch action here what
ends up happening is that while the
Fantastic Four are distracted with the
Negative Zone portal being open and
trying to find some way to shut it down
to scroll vessels starts showing up and
when they do what you end up getting is
this colossal scroll invasion of all
these different Scrolls who all
basically have any combination of
superheroes that you can conceivably
imagine they're launching their main
strike because the whole goal of the
Scrolls here is to keep the superheroes
distracted to keep them removed from the
landscape and then it's just mop up Duty
with the average person just wiping out
and annihilating all the just regular
denizens of Earth so by the time the
superheroes come back or at least
they're able to deal with their
Circumstance the Scrolls can take out
most of them and that actual invading
Army that we see here will just take out
the rest this basically picks up with
the Scrolls launching their invasion of
Earth now remember when it comes to
secret Invasion the campaign of the
Scrolls was launched in two fronts the
first one was basically duplicating
superheroes and then sending them to
Earth and sending the superhero
Community into a state of disarray
because you basically have like Iron Man
fighting Iron Man or Luke Cage fighting
Luke Cage and the superheroes themselves
are kind of asking each other are you a
scroll are you not a scroll and so it
creates distrust among the superhero
Community which is already fractured in
the aftermath of Civil War and so that
fracture begins to go even deeper the
other part of this was just a
traditional Invasion right aliens
arriving on Earth and just attacking
people and so that's really what kind of
goes on here they arrive at a baseball
game and of course you've got the mascot
kind of walking around doing mascot
stuff now the thing about this is it is
a Deadpool comic it's not going to be
serious it's going to be comedic just
the nature of things and so in fact when
they show up here they talk about the
nature of like the spirit of competition
that people have and so it's one of
those things whether like it's kind of
ironic that this this race of human
beings that's trying to find some
measure of Peace constantly engages in
competitive attitudes which basically
have their entire basis in warlike
tendencies so literally the human race
is leaning into its wartime or its
war-like mentality while trying to avoid
its warlike mentality at the same time
but the funny thing about this is they
basically have like this mascot right so
literally they analyze everybody here
and they're like okay so basically like
they're all humans except for that guy
now the Scrolls don't know what mascots
are they have no idea that it's
basically a human being running around
inside of an animal costume and trying
to trying to Hype up a crowd which
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't but once they Analyze This
mascot they realize that it's armed and
it's wearing body armor and outside of
basically any sporting event in the
south side of Chicago why in the world
would a mascot need to be armed and wear
body armor right like a Kevlar suit so
they end up firing on it and literally
like nothing happens but the mascot just
like like it looks like it's dead but it
looks like it's like like totally taken
out but then like it immediately pops up
and it's Deadpool with bullet holes and
everything and just opens fire on these
guys with Advanced Weaponry now the
funny thing here is at that point
they're like okay obviously this guy's
like some kind of an issue we got to
deal with this guy right we'll take him
out but they don't really see him as
being like overly important right and
that's one of the funny things is
Deadpool's usually one of those guys
where he's underestimated by people who
don't know who he is but the funny thing
is like as they're monitoring this whole
thing they're sending down troops right
to basically take care of what's you
know those individual people who are
there to take care of Deadpool but he's
just tearing them to pieces one because
of his advanced healing Factor right so
he can basically heal from pretty much
anything and two because of the fact
that the guys got just firearms and just
unloading everything on everyone now one
of the funny situations is when those
soldiers get down there Deadpool has
like the secondary voice in his head so
one of the things that's happened when
it came to Deadpool and Marvel Comics in
kind of a quick little history here is
you had Deadpool who was originally
introduced by Rob liefeld right so he
was like the super high octane
fast-paced superhero of like the 1990s
more of an anti-hero than anything else
but you didn't really know where his
Allegiance is lied he fought Wolverine
and cable for a little while that
bolstered his popularity because they
were so popular and then he started
dropping off in popularity because
people stopped buying comics in the late
1990s basically Joe Kelly started
writing Deadpool gave him more of like a
dark humor where he broke the fourth
wall a couple times Christopher priest
got his hands on Deadpool and he started
breaking the fourth wall all the time
and then Marvel started bringing in
things like additional voices inside of
his head to where he would basically
talk to himself and these different
voices have represented different
aspects of his character but that's why
you literally see him just conversing
with a voice in his own head because
it's kind of his moral compass to a
degree so it's almost like the narrator
explaining what's going on but the thing
about this is that as he's in this
situation and he's facing off against
these Scrolls as insane as it is he
basically starts seeing these Scrolls in
a way where they're like oh my God is
that Deadpool holy cow Deadpool we love
you man can we get your autograph and
that's when he's like I'm I'm
hallucinating again aren't I and the
voice in his head's like yeah they
basically because like they're shooting
at him and so he just starts attacking
all these guys just starts pummeling
them and so because of the fact that
he's just demolishing all these scroll
forces they do the only thing they can
do right because at this point their
Commander is just kind of frustrated and
he's fed up right he's like okay this
guy keeps cracking jokes he's taken out
our forces like come on guys it's one
man we're like the the scroll Empire
which is achieved Interstellar travel we
should be able to take this guy out
fairly quickly but the problem with this
is like as they're attacking this guy
like as they're attacking Deadpool he's
crushing their forces and so they end up
firing on him using their ships like
weapon cannons right which basically
like annihilates the mascot body which
leads them to believe that like he's
been killed the problem is when they get
to the mascot he's not there like he's
gone and in fact he's on top of the ship
and so what they end up doing and
realizing that is they dispatch the
super scroll now the super scroll is
kind of the Scrolls sort of prime weapon
right technically speaking the super
scroll was basically Asian member of the
scroll race who had all the powers of
the Fantastic Four what goes on here in
secret invasion is that the super scroll
has kind of changed his purpose to where
it's basically a combination of
different superheroes Powers so really
it's not really the super scroll in the
traditional sense it's not a scroll that
has the powers of the Fantastic Four
it's just a super scroll that has a
variety of powers unto themselves right
so kind of borrowing that concept and
changing it up a little bit but what
ends up happening is with Deadpool
basically on this ship he starts
planting these bombs and then detonates
them and actually incapacitates the ship
destroys the scroll ship and so when
that happens the whole thing comes
crashing down onto super scroll and
basically takes him out and so with
everybody basically you know at least
the the idea of them being dead you have
Deadpool who rolls into the scene right
and it's like okay he finds the
commander of the scroll Army right that
guy's basically alive he finds the
commander he walks up on him and he's
like okay so here's the thing right he's
like tell me does your scroll medical
plan cover massive head wounds on
bullets of the dome right like two in
the dome piece and so this guy's like
whatever like you know if you expect me
to bag for my life that's not gonna
happen like I'm not gonna beg and plead
whatever do your worst and so Deadpool
goes to pull the trigger and it's a fake
gun right one of those little pop guns
it just says bang and the guy's like
what in the world is going on here right
and so of course the super scroll
reemerges he attacks Deadpool and so he
literally seizes him and he's like did
you really believe you could take on the
full might of the scroll Empire and
Deadpool's response is no no no you you
don't understand right like you're
misinterpreting everything right this is
all part of my plan now the reality is
this is not Deadpool's plan it's
somebody else's plan Deadpool's working
for another guy and it's one of the
coolest things because Deadpool's like
okay just so you guys know I'm not here
to attack you I was here to get your
attention I was here to show you you
need a guy like me on your side if your
entire secret Invasion event is gonna go
off without a hit so here's the deal
Wade Wilson and reporting for Duty I'm
here to join your cause I'm here to help
you annihilate the entirety of the
superhero Community Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe but the thing about this
is kind of continuing this on right this
sort of shows us or or covers the
continuing invasion of the Scrolls
against Earth now one of the cool things
about this is we're going to get this
Revelation that may or may not be true
and I'm curious to see which one you
guys believe but I'm curious to see how
you guys feel about this but what this
does is it picks up after the collapse
of the shield Helicarrier right remember
that was one of the the strikes that was
launched by the Scrolls they launched a
multi-faceted strike against Earth that
initially they launched a strike against
the superheroes by literally just crash
landing a vessel into the Savage land
and when the various superheroes had
responded to it that you ended up having
them met by their former counterparts
right and we just didn't know which one
was which right was the Spider-Man who
had shown up in the Savage land what
he's the real Spider-Man or was it the
one that came out of the ship we didn't
really know exactly what was going on
and that was part of the confusion that
the Scrolls were creating is throwing
out doppelgangers and then forcing the
superheroes on Earth to actually
question whether or not they were
Scrolls and then to question their
teammates right just kind of sowing
doubt the other part of this was them
launching a traditional attack in the
city of New York as well as other places
around the world in addition to taking
down Shield their technology as well as
Stark Tech right so basically blinding
all forms of Intelligence on Earth so
nobody really knows what's going on
right so when you end up having Maria
Hill who again is the current director
of shield in Marvel Comics at least at
the time this story is being written
when she takes off to the surface of the
Helicarrier she's met by Jarvis now
Jarvis is historically The Avengers
Butler the fact that he's here and the
fact that the attack was launched of
course putting two and two together
Jarvis is a scroll which we already knew
for the most part right he was the one
that helped to orchestrate the attack
that took down shield and Stark Tech at
the same time but the fact that John
Jarvis is an inside man for the Scrolls
is a big deal because the Avengers are
pretty knowledgeable about how shield
works the fact that Jarvis is a bad guy
here means he's basically able to bring
down the Avengers right which is a
pretty significant moment the other part
of this is we basically switch over to
Camp Hammond now this requires a bit of
explanation for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with Marvel
Comics Camp Hammond is one and really
kind of the main site of the initiative
so the way this worked in Marvel Comics
is that as most of you guys know you had
Civil War and again we've talked about
this before so for those of you guys who
are familiar with this bear with me here
for a second when it came to Civil Wars
most of you guys know it was all fought
over superhero registration right that
if you were a person out there that had
superpowers whether you intended to use
them or not you had to register your
name your address the whole nine yards
with the federal government those
individuals who didn't want to sided
with Captain America those individuals
who did sided with Iron Man and this led
to a giant Rift in the superhero
Community ultimately Iron Man Reed
Richards Hank him Ant-Man those guys who
were on the side of registration they
effectively won and what they ended up
doing was implementing the 50-state
initiative which was literally a
government-sanctioned superhero team in
all 50 states in terms of planning it
was pretty great right it was pretty
awesome and the reality is I always
sided with registration because what
that does is it basically holds people
accountable whereas people like Captain
America didn't want to be held
accountable for the things they did
right otherwise they would have been on
the side of registration and so what
this means is that it kept Hammond you
have a kind of coming together of what
is in effect the most capable members of
the 50 state initiative not everybody
from the initiative is here it's
basically like the top of the class
right like those individuals who are
like in the one person of the class they
get straight A's for lack of a better
analogy here but they're basically
gathered because no one knows exactly
what's going on or at least they're not
being made aware of what's going on now
eventually they were told by some of the
individuals like Diamondback who kind of
run the Initiative Program in the
absence of Hank Pam and those guys and
essentially saying like they don't know
where the Avengers are Communications
with shield and Iron Man and all that
stuff is down right like nobody knows
how to get anybody they're literally
Flying Blind but then him basically
shows up out of nowhere and tells them
like there's an attack in the city of
New York this is what you've been
training for we have to go respond now
that's one of the things to understand
the idea behind the initiative and it
was an actual comic book line it wasn't
very good but it was an actual comic
book line uh the idea was to literally
train them and get them prepared so they
could actually be superheroes that could
help alongside the Avengers but that's
all they would really be for the most
part I mean the ones who were like the
absolute best they would go on and join
the Avengers proper but for the most
part The Avengers Initiative Program was
kind of like if we need help we will
call you right until you've proved that
you're a person that can actually stand
on the battlefield in a meaningful
capacity the reality here though is that
this is kind of an all hands on deck
situation and so where you have all
these Scrolls who had invaded the city
of New York and they're all basically
using some variation of a combination of
superhero powers or just direct
duplicates of superheroes Wolverine Iron
Man different things like that that you
do have like Vision who's here you also
have the Young Avengers right now here's
the kind of caveat here because you're
going to notice Wiccan around here when
it comes to Wiccan those of you guys who
aren't familiar with him Wiccan is
ridiculously powerful right like as the
son of the Scarlet Witch arguably he's
more powerful than she is depending on
what era of comics you're reading and
where his powers are he is destined to
become the the demiurge basically
meaning he's going to be the most
powerful being on Earth and quite
literally one of the most powerful
beings in the universe he hasn't quite
reached that point yet because he
doesn't have fine-tuned control of his
abilities on that scale but this is one
of those moments where basically Brian
Michael Bendis invokes a character
that's stupidly powerful but you never
actually see him use the full totality
of his abilities it's just kind of the
way Brian Michael Bendis writes he's
very inconsistent with his writing style
but at the end of the day of course you
have hulkling who initially responds now
hopeling is half scroll he's not a Hulk
right despite his name I know you're
like my initial thought when they first
introduced hulkling when I first got
into him was like okay we don't know his
entire bases is he like the son of the
Hulk or something like that no he's just
had scroll but he is a shape shifter and
he is a cool character but the thing
about this is because he's half scroll
he initially tries to play diplomats
right like hey guys I'm half scroll is
cool you guys got to stop you can't do
this but one of the things to remember
is the scroll Empire as it exists now it
really takes place in the aftermath of
Galactus destroying pretty much their
entire home world as well as a whole
host of the Scrolls being obliterated
themselves during the annihilation event
so all you really have left of the
scroll Empire is basically just a
religiously guided race which is being
led by their Queen for the most part and
so because of that they're really here
with religious fanaticism right like we
are destined to take this place this is
like our manifest Destiny essentially
and they're looking to conquer it right
like that's that's kind of what their
goal is here and as a result of that
there's no way to really bargain with
them right I mean when you have an
individual who is Guided by religious
zealotry whatever the religious figure
is that's the only person they're going
to listen to and so in the absence of
that religious figure they will believe
the person that they identify with the
most who claims to speak on behalf of
that religious figure in times of
desperation people will believe what
they want to believe and in the instance
of this it's the Scrolls believing that
their their end is nigh when a religious
figure pops up in the case of the queen
and saying I can lead us to greener
pastures they will follow her with
unwavering loyalty and that's exactly
what's happening here that's why you
can't bargain with them that's why you
can't talk them down because they
believe it's their mission from their
gods to conquer Earth and so where you
do have the initiative that steps in and
does what they can for the most part
they're a stopgap measure it's sticking
a piece of bubble gum on a leak in a
wall right it's going to hold for a
little bit but they're not going to save
the day and so what this does is it
switches over to the Savage land with
basically Jessica Drew Spider Woman now
previously we had talked about how the
queen was impersonating somebody she was
going forward to claim to be someone in
the secret Invasion event this is it
right she claims to be Spider-Woman
right like she literally took on the
form of Spider Woman now here's the
thing to understand there's more that
goes on here than simply the Scrolls
just taking on the form of a person they
have a whole process and it's really
really cool it's pretty badass but of
course when she shows up here she
immediately takes out Echo now of course
a lot of you guys may know Echo from the
Hawkeye TV series she's been around in
Marvel Comics for a little while she was
never important no one ever really cared
about her she was just there
occasionally and did some stuff and was
interesting sometimes I guess it wasn't
until Marvel decided they were going to
put her in the Hawkeye show that in the
comics they started to elevate her they
gave her the Phoenix Force and all that
kind of stuff here's the funny thing
people still don't care so I mean she's
not an interesting character and she
never was
she's not cool because she's basically
task master right like she can copy the
fighting styles of other people been
there done that right I mean that's
literally all it is when it comes to her
character so that's why people never
really cared about her too much but the
thing about this is Jessica Drew takes
out Echo immediately like right off the
bat incapacitates her now there is a
reason why the queen chose Spider-Woman
above everybody else and we'll cover
that when we go into like the
transformation process when the Scrolls
take on the form of somebody else
because there is a huge motivation and
it's really really cool but what she
ends up doing is basically traveling to
see Tony Stark now one of the things to
know is that when the secret Invasion
event first kicked off and like
technology really like start taking
everything went offline what it also
meant is that Tony Stark's suit was not
really capable of keeping his body safe
the way that it previously had he's
literally dying right that's literally
what's happening his fever is like 102.
his body's basically shutting down and
so he's trying to find a way to get his
suit back up and running again now the
thing about this is when Jessica shows
up he's kind of like look no offense
girl but like I don't really want to
talk to anybody I have to focus on
trying to find a way to fix this suit
now under any normal circumstance Tony
Stark would do this in an instant right
this suit would be sorted out quick fast
and in a hurry but one of the things to
remember is that they're in the Savage
land right and we talked about this in a
previous video The Savage land is out
there in Antarctica somewhere sure it's
been a place that's been explored and
used by multiple people over the years
Mr Sinister Magneto right like hazar who
nobody cares about he's basically
Marvel's Tarzan but like it's been used
by a lot of different people but the
technology is archaic right so this is
basically Tony Stark trying to fix his
suit in a cave with a box of scraps
that's literally what this is right he
can only do so much with the archaic
technology that's available here but the
funny thing is that when Jessica shows
up when the queen shows up here she
actually starts screwing with the mind
of Tony Stark right what she says is
like your work on Earth is done right
thank you Tony Stark for everything that
you've accomplished here and he's like
what in the world are you talking about
right her response is you will go down
in our people's history as the greatest
Soldier the Armada has ever had and you
will always and forever have my undying
love the love of your queen and where
she's trying to convince Tony Stark that
he's a scroll he refuses to believe that
it's true but here's one of the things
you remember this is him speaking and
it's really him just trying to convince
himself that's the kicker here right and
again we'll go more into this process in
a future video but when the Scrolls take
on the form of superheroes it's not just
copying them they believe they're that
person it's one of the things that Tony
Stark figured out right at the very
beginning of the story that we started
covering here it's one of the things
that Tony Stark realized when Electro
was revealed to be a scroll the reason
why her mind couldn't be read by
telepaths and they couldn't figure out
that she was a scroll the reason why she
didn't smell like a scroll to Wolverine
is because for all intents and purposes
and by all standards of measurement they
or that person right they genuinely
believe that they are that person and so
when the queen comes along and uses that
information against Tony Stark it leads
Tony Stark down the path of doubting
himself perhaps I really am a scroll
which is why he's trying to basically
convince himself in saying this as
opposed to talking to her and it's kind
of the funny thing because she says like
you performed admirably Tony Stark none
of this would have been possible had it
not been for you right you initiated the
superhero Civil War you became director
of Shield you're the one that basically
ignored the entirety of the Scrolls
secretly replacing all of these
different superheroes on Earth had it
not been for you we never would have
been able to pull this off now this
conversation is ridiculously important
especially when it comes to the end of
secret Invasion and then you start going
into dark rain which we may or may not
cover I don't know if we're gonna do
that or not it's a cool story arc it's
not really an event it's more of like a
branding initiative but I'll make sense
of it once we get closer to the end of
of secret Invasion once we get to the
end of secret Invasion but the thing
about this is that it's a really really
important conversation here but in a lot
of ways she's using the history of Tony
Stark against him because he did
initiate the superhero Civil War and he
did become director of shield and it was
under his watch as director of Shield
that the Scrolls were secretly replacing
superheroes he was part of the
Illuminati the Illuminati were the ones
who went to the scroll home world in the
first place and set all this in motion
by telling the Scrolls never to visit
earth right remember when we covered
that one shot the Scrolls had
incapacitated the Illuminati and started
analyzing their DNA and came to the
realization we can copy their
superpowers right it's not simply us
just taking on their forms if we explore
this possibility long enough not only
can we copy the forms of superheroes on
Earth we can copy their powers and then
we can make it impossible for them to
detect the fact that we are Scrolls
right we can push this to its limit and
so jumping back to Manhattan back at
Times Square where this main event's
going on as you would expect the
initiative is getting absolutely wrecked
right and the crazy thing about this is
that this is all being recorded it's all
being broadcast live on TV so quite
literally the entirety of the earth is
watching as the superheroes in New York
who are really like the last stand right
they're the ones that are supposed to
keep the world protected they're getting
obliterated by the forces of the Scrolls
even vision is destroyed by the Scrolls
themselves because remember they've been
prepping for this war for quite some
time they've been studying the
superheroes long enough to know how to
overcome their various abilities so
destroying Vision destroying these other
members of the superhero Community all
basically seems lost but in the midst of
all of this everything around the
entirety of New York starts to shake
literally the whole city starts shaking
and what ends up happening is Nick Fury
and his Howling Commandos emerge with
Daisy Johnson leading the charge now
here's something that I want to solidify
here right and this it's one of the
things that I hated the most about
Agents of Shield Agents of Shield was a
cool show it was an interesting show
they de-powered Quake so bad it was
ridiculous Daisy Johnson in the comics
is stupidly powerful I mean she's one of
these characters where this it's
arguable that she's Omega Level because
she can literally create earthquakes to
the point that she could actually
shatter worlds it's not how overpowered
she is but in the show she was it was I
mean I get the mcud powers people that's
just the nature of things just how the
MCU works but she was so weak compared
to her comic book version and that's
going to be nuts because while Nick
Fury's team is here and they they are
gonna put a dent in the Scrolls even
Daisy Johnson's power and her ability to
create earthquakes on virtually any
scale is not really going to be enough
to turn the tide what we end up doing
here is we initially pick up with
Deadpool right now as you guys know
Deadpool in the last video that we
talked about had based basically join
the Scrolls quote unquote what we're
gonna end up finding out is this is just
a giant ruse that what Deadpool does is
the kind of pitches himself to the
Scrolls in the sense that he's a guy
who's always kind of been cast out from
the superhero community and in that way
it's true right that's an actual
accurate statement by Deadpool the
superhero Community had never really
taken him that seriously at all and so
as a kind of cast out himself he wanted
to basically end the entirety of the
Earth's population or at least that's
how he pitched himself right he was
siding with the Scrolls and so what he
ends up doing is effectively telling
them that because he is so unique
regarding his healing Factor well the
scrolls are initially going to take him
out and then just copy his healing
factor and call it a day his response is
but like they don't they don't know how
to fight like I5 right it's one thing to
have my healing Factor but at that point
you're just throwing an endless number
of Scrolls at the superheroes in the
hopes that you can somehow defeat them
whereas if I can train your scroll
soldiers how to fight once they have my
healing Factor you can do whatever you
want with me but in effect you won't
have to kill so many of your your own
kind and that's one of the things to
keep in mind while the Scrolls do see
this as a wartime campaign and while
they are willing to make sacrifices to
achieve their goal they're not willing
to throw lives away we're going you know
in order to to have it done right
they're not Russia during World War II
they're not killing retreating soldiers
and so as a result of this Deadpool
literally takes those Scrolls who have
been given his healing factor and starts
training them how to fight but as you
guys know Deadpool's crazy as hell so
not only does he teach them how to fight
he also basically turns them into crazy
people now initially the Scrolls don't
quite know what to make of this and
they're kind of like I mean
these guys going nuts like this are they
supposed to be doing that and it's like
well we have to trust Deadpool or we
have to trust that this guy knows what
he's doing that he knows what he's
talking about the funny thing about this
is that as time goes on he basically
gets these guys to a point where they
all literally start killing each other
right like all these scroll soldiers
that have been given Deadpool's healing
Factor all basically just start taking
each other out and the reason why this
matters is because one Deadpool had
basically had these weapons retrofitted
so these guys could be destroyed if they
needed to be but the second thing behind
this is that this is all a ploy right
this is all a ruse the whole purpose
behind Deadpool doing this was to gain
the trust of the Scrolls to get inside
their ship so he could feed information
and he's giving us information to Nick
Fury now I told you guys at the very
beginning of secret Invasion when we
cover this and as always you'll find a
link to the playlist down in the
description so you can get caught up
that what Nick Fury had been doing was
secretly operating behind the scenes in
order to secure every bit of information
he could from every Source he could and
so that's exactly what's going on here
now as for what's going on back on Earth
and actually in the satellite itself we
switch over to Abigail brand now
remember Abigail brand is the leader of
Sword which is basically Shield except
they monitor space and where their space
station was like one of the first things
to be taken out by the Scrolls that way
Humanity was blinded in terms of what
was going on out in space which of
course allowed the scroll forces to
basically properly invade that Abigail
brand had also learned that Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four had been
taken by the Scrolls now a lot of that
was done just because of the fact that
when it came to the Scrolls themselves
Reed Richards his intelligence is
universally recognized he's largely
basically seen as the smartest person in
the universe so having his knowledge at
their disposal and really kind of
tormenting and torturing him due to the
fact that he was part of the original
Illuminati that having him there is a
huge asset for the Empire with Abigail
brand basically being the leader of
sword and then freeing Reed Richards
they end up based basically transporting
back to Earth and then of course we
transition over to Maria Hill whose
Helicarrier was taken down by the scroll
forces and ultimately ambushed by Jarvis
who's normally The Avengers Butler but
turned out to be a scroll now one of the
things that she was told early on by
Nick Fury of course again if you guys
recall when the two of them had met then
Nick Fury had said make sure you get
some life model decoys you're surrounded
by nothing but enemies you just don't
know it yet Maria Hill despite the fact
that she is exceedingly arrogant in
Marvel Comics despite the fact that she
usually always believes she's right and
can never really admit when she's wrong
ultimately ended up going with the
information Nick Fury gave her because
if Nick Fury is nothing it's usually
always correct and so as a result of
that she basically got a life model
decoy and so when Jarvis and his forces
open up on Maria Hill when they open
fire on her it's of course a life model
decoy they destroy which allows the real
Maria Hill to basically take off and so
what we end up doing is kind of joining
the rest of the superheroes on Earth and
basically the the conclusion of the
secret Invasion event at least the
proper conclusion to this event right so
switching over to Deadpool what ends up
happening here is of course Deadpool
with all these forces being taken out
the initial intention of the Scrolls is
to locate and find Deadpool they end up
sitting super Scroll after him of course
Deadpool takes that guy out pretty
easily I mean that's one of the things
to know is that at the end of the day
Deadpool's easily able to overcome those
guys because when it comes to the super
scroll he's just an amalgamation of the
earth superhero Powers right Deadpool's
face off against those guys multiple
times so he knows how to basically
overcome all of them and so what this
does is he basically ends up leading
what's left of these scroll soldiers who
have all started mutating and everything
now and literally destroys the Deadpool
Scrolls right as well as what's left of
the scroll forces following that he ends
up taking information that would be
Paramount to destroying the secret
Invasion Fleet right the squirrel Fleet
and he essentially teleports it or sends
it to Nick Fury the crazy thing about
this is that while this is bio data
right that can basically kill to kill
the scroll Queen when the information
sent it's supposed to go to Nick Fury
but instead it's intercepted by Norman
Osborne now that's why I told you guys
when we covered the Thunderbolt story
Norman Osborne was going to be the
single most important character in this
story or at least one of the most
important characters in this whole story
because it's this action right here that
basically changes everything right so
what we end up doing is switching back
to Earth when the Scrolls basically make
their statement to the World At Large
and it's really cool because what they
say here is as you know your Global
communication systems are fully restored
we apologize for the inconvenience of
taking them down this is a time for
unheralded transition for your world as
it becomes part of the scroll Empire for
those of you who are understandably
confused and panicked let me explain it
to you very clearly your lives will go
on as they were you get to keep your
homes your culture your family your jobs
we are not taking anything away from you
we're only adding things you'll notice
that the scroll Empire has made no
offensive moves towards your armies or
your governments we have only defended
ourselves when necessary and we request
that all armed forces ignore whatever
orders you've received from your
Superior officers and stand down now
this is a very important thing on a
variety of different levels what Brian
Michael Bendis is doing here is actually
drawing on the superhero's perception
and really the world's perception
following a story called maximum
security so maximum security was a story
that was written in Marvel Comics back
in the 90s I think and the whole idea
behind this is that the the cree race
had actually taken over Earth and turned
it into a prison planet and in fact Ron
and the accuser was basically the warden
of Earth at that point in time meaning
Humanity has been down this road before
and so when the Scrolls show up here and
it's like hey hey guys we're here we're
on your side we're not going to take
anything away from you what they're in
effect saying here is that we're not
going to do what the cree did during
maximum security we're not not going to
turn you into prisoners your lives will
continue on the way they always had you
won't really notice a discernible
difference here now the other part of
this is the scrolls are lying right
they're literally asking soldiers to
basically ignore orders from their
Superior officers which would make it
easier for the Scrolls to basically take
them all out but it's also a very very
smart maneuver because of what use is a
military officer if he's surrounded by
soldiers that won't obey his orders but
following Reed Richards basically
arriving at the Savage land with Abigail
brand at this point with Reed Richard's
arrival because he's been stuck on the
scroll ship all this time once he's here
they're able to tell pretty fast that is
actually read and following that he
literally galvanizes the superheroes and
brings them together now a lot of that's
because one of the things to remember is
the Fantastic Four is like the first
family of Marvel Comics so in a lot of
ways even though the Fantastic Four
don't usually get involved in the
traditional superhero Antics meaning
they're not facing off against like
Thanos or something like that they're
usually out exploring things a lot of
that's because they've done their dirt
quote unquote right they fought their
share of bad guys and they've done their
thing they've kind of moved beyond that
right they've been promoted to a
managerial position it's the best
analogy that I can make and so with that
in mind read Richards is highly
respected by the superhero Community
which is why they listen to him right
that in his level of intelligence and so
on but the other part of this is again
Tony Stark's struggling now there's what
Tony Stark struggles with publicly then
there's what Tony Stark struggles with
privately publicly people are just kind
of like you know his statement to people
is start Tech is down and this and this
and that and that and so on and so forth
what he actually struggles with on a
more private level is that the world's
going to see him as a failure because
remember at this point in time in Marvel
Comics this takes place after Civil War
which means Tony Stark is the director
of Shield all this happened under his
watch and the world is going to ask the
question why and when that question does
get asked he's ultimately going to end
up losing his position he knows that and
in fact we know that and so what's
really cool about this is you kind of
have people responding right the average
person responding in a couple different
ways some actually side with the Scrolls
right if Humanity could get it together
Humanity would have already gotten it
together like the fact that Humanity
just hasn't gotten it together yet means
Humanity doesn't want to so if he if the
human race won't change then someone
needs to force the human race to change
and the scrolls are doing that and so is
that a good thing because the the the
cost of that is that the world would be
basically turned into a prison planet so
again this presents some really
interesting philosophical arguments to
how this kind of situation can be
approached but the reality is that it's
the superheroes facing off against the
Scrolls which is one of the reasons why
I always love this story because one of
the ideas that I've always put out there
is that superheroes don't really exist
to like make the world better
superheroes exist to maintain the status
quo right you could argue superheroes
are actually the bad guys so it's really
interesting you know in terms of how
things function but nonetheless what
this does is this actually coincides
with the return of Thor now here's the
thing to understand about this right one
of the things to know is that not only
is Thor here but you also have Bucky
Captain America so secret invasion was
one of those stories that Marvel wrote
where it was kind of a transitionary
story think of it as one of many that
Marvel was writing at the time they were
like the equivalent of Empire Strikes
Back in the Star Wars Mythos right that
this was a story that was designed to
one properly introduce us or really have
us see the real and new Bucky Barnes
Captain America he did get his own solo
comic for a time but Steve Rogers was
killed he was assassinated by by agent
13 Sharon Carter who had basically been
duped right she was more or less being
hypnotized when it was done by The Red
Skull and his forces so Bucky Barnes
ended up taking up the mantle and Bucky
Barnes became the new Captain America
but the other part about this is that
during the events of Thor disassembled
or Thor Ragnarok as was colloquially
known by fans that that was the death of
Thor right during the events of Civil
War Tony Stark had cloned Thor and
that's where you got the Ragnarok cyborg
version but this version you see here is
the one that returned during J Michael
strzinski's run he's been traveling
around Earth and basically waking up the
Asgardian Spirits or the Essences of the
various asgardians who were who have
basically been reborn in human form and
then bringing them to Asgard which he
had rebuilt in Broxton Oklahoma and so
that's kind of been his thing for a
little bit now and this actually takes
place after the events of basically Thor
beating the hell out of Iron Man if you
guys never saw that it was just an
amazing moment I'm pretty sure we did a
video on it it was really really cool
but the thing about this is that it's
kind of the superheroes returning to a
degree right kind of stepping back into
the normal landscape and so again what
you end up getting here is just a great
big huge massive battle that takes place
between the scroll forces and Earth
superheroes pretty straightforward not a
whole lot doing here it's one of the
things that I hope you guys notice is
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe very
much models the form and function of its
movies after the way that Marvel Comics
writes their comic books right like
here's the exposition here's what's
going on now time for the big battle
which is always the same no matter what
movie you're watching right it's that
kind of a thing right it's the way it
works and honestly it's a multi-billion
dollar franchise who's to argue against
that although I do think it's time for
the MCU to start changing and I'll make
a video on that you know on uh on my
video essays on geek culture explained
which will be coming at some point in
the future no I haven't abandoned that
channel so here's the thing right with
this massive battle is taking place here
it's pretty straightforward again it's
Heroes fighting Scrolls and that's
really more or less it right just kind
of a battle between these characters and
really things are pretty straightforward
the big thing about this is remember
Jessica Drew is the scroll Queen it's
the person she chose to be we covered
that in the last video that the scroll
Queen chose Jessica Drew because of her
kind of time basically gravitating
around the superhero landscape she's
friends with Spider-Man she's been a
part of the Avengers she is a social
appreciated with the X-Men even if she's
not the closest person to them she's
been a an agent that's worked with Hydra
she literally has had her hands in
everything so to basically take control
of her or to replace her means to have
access to the entirety of really the
superhero and even super villain
landscape in Marvel Comics now of course
as is always when it comes to stuff like
this you have the Watcher who appears
because you know in the mid-2000s The
Watcher always showed up it was like oh
this is this event is going to be a big
event and everything's going to change
because of this it was it stopped
mattering after a while which is always
kind of disappointing but as the battle
rages on and the Earth superheroes were
able to overcome the forces of the
Scrolls at least in terms of this battle
basically the scroll Queen is the only
one left but she refuses to give ground
because she's a religious believer she's
driven by religious convictions she
truly believes that Earth is the
rightful place of the scroll Empire
following the almost complete
destruction of their race during
Annihilation and the destruction of
their Homeworld by Galactus and so
because she's driven by such convictions
she refuses to give ground so this
ultimately leads to Wolverine launching
an attack with the attention of killing
her but she's killed before that happens
and it's done by Norman Osborne because
Norman is the one who intercepts the
information from Deadpool that the
scroll Queen is the one you have to
assassinate and here's the person that
she is she's Jessica Drew that's the
whole reason why Norman Osborne even
sent the Thunderbolts into this battle
in the first place under any normal
circumstance Norman Osborne wouldn't
really care and in fact he would sit
back and wait to see which side he
should choose based on which side is
most likely to win if the Earth
superheroes are most likely to win it's
hey guys the Thunderbolts are here to
help I mean we're no we're not going to
change the tide but like we have to do
something here right we've just been
dealing with our own major crisis or if
the Scrolls were winning then it's just
like hey Scrolls I'm the guy you want on
your side right like that kind of a
thing now the other part of this is that
because this battle was so highly
televised the whole world sees Norman
Osborne taking this killing blow which
means that as far as everybody is
concerned Norman Osborne is the one who
ended the threat now that's immensely
important here because what we end up
finding out is that without the scroll
Queen and without any kind of a superior
officer no one knows who to take their
orders from and so literally the whole
scroll not really the race but those
individuals who are here they kind of
fall into disarray and disorganization
which is long enough for those
superheroes that can operate in space
Thor and Captain Marvel and those guys
to basically take out the scroll forces
that are out there and so once the dust
settles and everything is all cleared up
it basically leads to Tony Stark and
literally destroying pretty much all of
the ships out there except for one and
the reason why is because on that ship
are the superheroes that were replaced
with scroll duplicates that's kind of in
the question that a lot of you guys have
been asking you've basically been
wondering if the Scrolls have replaced
superheroes what happened to the
original superheroes they basically they
just kind of been sitting on a ship this
is kind of a Brian Michael Bendis hand
wavy explanation right like I mean why
because literally in the comic the
questions asked why didn't the Scrolls
just kill them after they duplicated
them and it's like well they they
probably needed them for genetic
material in case you know they could
somehow increase their abilities or
something like that it's literally
Marvel just kind of hand waving the
explanation away but the fact is all
these different superheroes have all
essentially returned and so that's when
the discussion starts to be had where do
we go from here how does everybody pick
up these pieces how does it all make
sense and one of the things that we find
out here is that because Tony Stark had
failed because Tony Stark had never seen
the secret Invasion coming that what the
US government literally did was stand
against Tony Stark they kicked him out
as director of Shield right they were
like you were literally you had all the
world's intelligence at your disposal
right you're the one that said after
Civil War that you could keep us safe
that you could protect us from the
various threats of the world the first
threat we get which is the Scrolls
secretly replacing superheroes you miss
right you are a terrible director of
Shield they kick him out and they
replace them with Norman Osborne now a
lot of you guys are probably asking how
can Norman Osborne be replaced the
reality here is that the government is
really more about public perception than
anything else and as far as the world is
concerned Norman Osborne saved the day
you combined that with Norman Osborne's
nickel slick smile and his silver tongue
and there's literally no question that
this guy could weasel his way in the
funny thing about this is that as soon
as Norman Osborne is made the new
director of shield and he's basically
given Avengers Tower right they hand it
to him this guy runs in Avengers tower
now as soon as it's handed over to him
he goes into an elevator he goes to an
underground bunker he meets with Namor
the Submariner Mephisto Loki who's a
chick now Emma Frost from the hellfire
club kind of the X-Men she's kind of a
good guy bad guy and Doctor Doom forming
his own cabal and basically really
initiating the events of dark rain and
dark rain was great oh my God I loved
dark rain it's literally like dark rain
for those of you guys who don't know
it's not really a story arc it's not
like dark rain part one part two part
three it's more like dark Avengers dark
X-Men stuff like that but it's basically
Norman Osborne's attempt to use the
forces of Shield to conquer the world
it's awesome it's just it's one of the
coolest stories that Marvel had written
for a long long time but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
Bruce